[Music]
lady gaga's have the most incredible
year movie star Oscar winner and now
Queen no doubt in my mind of the Met
Gala
[Applause]
how do you feel right now you look like
bananas
I look like bananas but I feel very
glamorous
the big question of tonight is how on
earth is katy perry gonna get her
chandelier dress up the Met Gala stairs
let's just say she walked very carefully
in the 40 pound ensemble it's the kind
of look that's 24/7 you know what I'm
saying
you wake up in the morning go to bed
with it it works I'm so cool ooh we were
a sucker for the Jonas newly married
couples debut on the red carpet we like
spending time together to get to spend
time together looking this outrageous is
perfect and party be needed six escorts
to carry her very heavy train up the Met
Gala stairs we really was trying to make
sure that a very elegant extravagant but
not so Halloween is hotter Billy Porter
arrived with six choreograph dancers
carrying him onto the red carpet tell
everyone that doesn't understand camp
what camp is camp is the art of being
extra that's what the camp call it today
speaking of camp share was the surprise
performer
and when Stefani sang along the living
legend was introduced by Lady gaga who
co-hosted the event
lady gaga arrives first
[Music]
and the queen of the Met Gala or should
we just call it the Met Gaga didn't
disappoint
mother monster worked the carpet in not
one but four different looks with Lady
gaga at the mess
gaga in a 25-foot hot pink train stepped
onto the carpet with five handlers also
at her side designer brandon maxwell
helping her strip her way through a 13
minute and 30 second show-stopping
entrance this is her second costume
change and I believe there is a third
underneath this is so major
[Music]
are you reuniting for another movie
and down she goes again to the beginning
of the carpet
Gaga saved the most jaw-dropping look
for last
dripping in 1.7 million dollars worth of
Tiffany's diamonds but little else
another accessory a pink wagon filled
with three bottles of champagne and two
hats we counted Gaga climbing the iconic
Met steps four times in those 10-inch
heels Gaga worked the campy look a
sequined bra and underwear the rest of
the night and no doubt all eyes were on
her in the form of being yourself what
do you think Blake would look like in
camp solo Gwen nailed camp coupled up
JLo not so much more than this new
fiance hey rod let fans decide his tux
color is he and JLo marked two years at
the Met you're back again and now you're
gonna get married Alex what do you think
it's very exciting and right down the
street from Yankee Stadium
I've always been her solo so it's I wore
higher heels because I had someone to
hold me this time quick changing Miley
and Liam celebrated four months of
marriage with a lick and a tango while
costumes switched up Nick and Priyanka
popped the champagne to ring in two
years since being each other's Met Gala
dates this time were married
Nick also trolled new sister-in-law
Sophie posting this with her G ot
nemesis Turner's response oh I thought
you died last season heard a new hubby
Joe but Sophie got a hug in with thrones
co-star Richard Madden inside undercover
couple no more Katie and Jamie made
their debut Kim at Nate $43 jacket
wearing Kanye made it a family affair
with their fourth child due any day now
I heard there was rumors he was coming
today but meanwhile Chris Pratt will
soon get a future brother-in-law
he's honestly such a great guy so I'm
happy for my sister that's all you want
is a brother to have your sister happy
and from fast friends to enemies I can't
tell you the secret because I have to
kill you Nikki and cardi had competing
trains but Minaj wasn't boasting a half
a million dollar Ruby bejeweled bosom if
I lose one of them you know what I'm
saying i'ma have to throw my Birkin bag
from carnies crazy pieces to the campus
accessory on the carpet Jarrod's head
made by an Italian special effects
company and Gucci Gucci Gucci head Kacey
Musgraves was Barbie all the way from
her car to her clutch the purse hold
anything it's an actual blow dryer but
it does hold stuff my lipsticks in there
of course Barbie Atsuko Muslims
and headpieces were big literally from
Katie's lit look to Priyanka's crown and
Celine's feathers it's an homage to the
end of your Vegas of time with the
headpiece everything that I feel that at
my best without something pretentious
it's the beginning of something it's not
an end but it's the beginning gigi hadid
rocks some icicles on her lashes Harry
Styles and Elle Fanning showed off some
nail art sometimes you are the art one
of our favorite accessories of the night
the one that set zendaya
a glow all Cinderella like she even had
a carriage for a purse Naomi Campbell
had her personal fan to keep her
feathers flowing and gala co-chair
Serena Williams was comfy on the carpet
rocking some sneakers under her custom
Versace serena whose idea was the
speaker
of course the party didn't stop after
the met calabash Katie gave her after
party ensemble the works she transformed
into a hamburger lettuce mini dress and
burger shoes Katy switched it up inside
the Met Gala bathroom and JLo barely
gave it a second look a JLo so why a
burger we're thinking it's a nod to
fiancee Orlando they met when he swiped
one off her table at a 2016 Golden
Globes afterparty
Celine Dion approved the look then Katy
rolled up to the next stop and bastino
and Jeremy Scott afterparty
that's where Gwen Stefani slipped into a
sparkly mini worthy of the front page
[Music]
we're done I got a filter on Kim
Kardashian stuck with the water theme
wearing rain drop inspired mini for her
after-party Lupita Nyong'o Janelle Monae
and Danai gurira were ready to let loose
inside
Kim sister Kylie wore a gown that was a
smidge my little pony her late night
look I didn't know what to think when I
heard the theme was going to be camp
this year but this is my favorite Met
theme ever and I would like it to be
camp gala forever
everyone who showed up did not
disappoint in any way but there were
some all-star absences including Beyonce
Rihanna Taylor Swift and Blake Lively
they are Met Gala regulars who ended up
skipping this year
[Music]
[Applause]